il est 20h30 au QG de Valérie Pécresse
les premières estimations tombent la
présidente sortante de la région
Île-de-France est donnée gagnante face à
l'Union de la gauche au rassemblement
national et à la République en marche
d'abord par notre fermeté notre
attention au territoire ruraux nous
avons fait baisser le rassemblement
national par notre clarté nous avons
fait gagner les forces de la droite et
du centre dans une région où la majorité
présidentielle avait décidé d'engager 5
ministres par notre incarnation d'une
écologie des résultats nous avons prouvé
que l'écologie n'appartenait à aucun
camp très clairement Valérie Pécresse
est aujourd'hui celle qui va conduire
l'Île-de-France celle qui a aussi
apporté un certain nombre de choses au
pays le résultat est confirmé dans la
soirée à 45,92 % avec un écart de 12
points face à la liste de l'union de la
gauche la droite et le centre
accroissent son avance par rapport à
2015 le résultat de ce soir c'est
vraiment la preuve que même dans une
région qui est difficile dans une région
qui a été gagnée de peu en 2015 qui a
connu une alternance quand le résultat
sont là les électeurs restent fidèles et
sont fidèles et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
que l'écart soit aussi net et bien c'est
vraiment une une validation de ce
travail qui a été fait pendant 5 ans
dans une région je le redis qui est
difficile normalement pour la droite
donc je crois que Valérie Pécresse fait
une prouesse ce soir par ce travail
quand voilà on a des résultats on tient
cette promesse de campagne comme on l'a
fait avec celle de 2015 et bien les
électeurs le reconnaissent ils
reconnaissent le bilan qui a été fait il
reconnaisse qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
travail à accomplir ils veulent nous ils
nous renouvelle leur confiance pour
continuer ses transformations dans tout
un tas de secteurs sur l'emploi avec la
relance économique dans l'écologie les
transports les lycées à 21h15 la
présidente réélu de la région
Île-de-France quitte son QG direction un
hôtel du 18e arrondissement une soirée
organisée dans cet établissement pour
célébrer sa victoire avec ses colistiers
et l'ensemble des membres de la campagne
électorale ce deuxième mandat ça va être
celui de la concrétisation de toute une
série d'investissements qu'on a lancé
que ce soit dans le lycée que ce soit
dans les transports que ce soit en
matière en matière économique on va en
matière d'emploi en matière de formation
on va avec ce deuxième mandat pouvoir
encore amplifier tout ce qu'on a fait si
le travail de ce deuxième mandat
commence dès aujourd'hui une autre
échéance électorale est dans les esprits
la présidentielle de 2022 malgré
l'abstention ce double scrutin régional
départemental permet de tirer des
enseignements en réalité en vue de 2022
il n'y a pas uniquement Emmanuel Macron
et Marine Le Pen et que le match est
beaucoup plus ouvert ce soir c'est aussi
la preuve que désormais pour la droite
et le centre c'est un match à 3 il vous
a pas échappé que Valérie Pécresse a
toujours été une femme politique
nationale qu'elle avait beaucoup de
choses à dire et que sa victoire est
aussi le signe que lorsqu'on est ferme
sur les valeurs de la République
lorsqu'on obtient des résultats les
Français vous sont reconnaissants et
vous en et donc peut-être que c'est
aussi un bon présage pour l'avenir mais
avant de se pencher sur le rassemblement
de sa famille politique en vue de
l'élection présidentielle Valérie
Pécresse a rendez-vous le vendredi 2
juillet 2021 pour l'installation du
nouveau conseil régional